hi i'm john cho i play spike spiegel on
cowboy bebop uh i am daniela pineda and
i play faye valentine and i'm mustafa
shakir and i play jet black hi i'm alex
hassell and i play vicious in cowboy
bebop hi i'm elena sateen and i play
julia and today we are here with
buzzfeed to take a quiz to find out
which character we are i really have no
idea
[Music]
first what would be your go-to snack on
a bounty hunting mission the choices are
popcorn
cookies potato chips candy trail mix no
snacks just a good whiskey i know mine
what's yours a trail mix we're gonna
need energy mine too i'm trail mix we're
trail mix across the board what i
thought you for sure was gonna be a
whiskey what are you
no hunch
no punch no punch i don't i was that's
weird
i'm gonna say because we're not
currently on a cowboy beatbox training
regime i'm gonna say candy if chocolate
is included in candy then it would
that's what i was assuming um but if if
the no snacks was just a good glass of
wine then it would have been that but
i'm gonna go with candy candy which
cowboy bebop character would you want to
go on an adventure with gran anna jet
black iron spike spiegel faye valentine
i'm picking jet black because he's
reliable he's no bull he's a dad at
heart i feel like i would be safe with
him i'm going with anna because she's
connected that's true actually she's
really she i feel like she would have a
spot in any city and a guy
and a hook-up
and all that she's like the wolf yeah it
would be first class man i shouldn't
have heard that answer it's good all
right we're going to go with jet black
i'm going to go i'm going to take an
adventure with jet black narcissus for
me it's ein obviously because i love
dogs so i'm going to go i'm going to go
i'm going to go fave valentine because i
want to hear her expletive
laden comedy what
is your greatest strength loyalty
creativity dedication honesty courage
endurance i pick courage it's only
because i'm impulsive it's just
impulsivity mass discourage i'll go with
dedication i feel like once i get stuck
on something pretty hard to shake he's a
barnacle i'm a whiskey drinking barnacle
for a jet which is i mean dedication
he's the black dog once i bite down i
don't let go probably honesty i'm not
sure my wife would agree that that is my
greatest strength but um i'm fairly
honest to a fault i think i would say
loyalty choose an anime series to binge
watch sailor moon naruto
full metal alchemist brotherhood attack
on titan death note my hero academia
sailor moon without a doubt i don't know
any of these
uh what do you suggest sailor moon it's
the best
you have a daughter so sailor moon okay
be careful what you sign on um
death note well i've seen death note so
i don't need to binge watch it i think
i'm gonna go attack on titan just
because there's some cowboy bebop link
in the um grand and vicious fort full
metal alchemist what was your dream job
when you were a kid singer firefighter
doctor detective actor
chef my dream job was to be a singer
definitely detective that was you know
that was what i was really i was reading
all those detective books when i was a
kid i wanted to be an actor funny enough
basically
um watching different strokes i was like
i i i i know i secretly really want to
be a chef so i'm just gonna pick chefs
just because it would be i mean i think
that's it
it was really lovely i'm gonna i mean
embarrassingly
just an actor that's so very
single-minded very boring that's all
i've ever wanted okay and finally pick
an iconic sci-fi movie star trek 2 the
wrath of khan dune alien blade runner
arrival
star wars and new hope alien and blade
runner i'm gonna have to go with one of
them i think probably blade runner just
because i wish i was harrison ford i'll
go with alien alien's pretty great and i
do have a confession to make i've never
actually seen a star wars movie from
beginning to end wow so
yeah i know a lot of people are not
gonna like that you have to pick that so
you can actually rectify that no no it
has to be alien alien is amazing alien's
amazing i have to go with alien blade
runner the wrath of khan is an excellent
freaking movie you were in star trek so
you kind of don't have a choice all
right i'll pick the wrath of khan come
on
i'm spike spiegel i'm jet black no
wonder i love jet so much come on i'm
spike spiegel this makes sense mike
speaker well yeah that makes sense for
me too i'm a uh are you spike's beagle
yeah interesting i want to know what if
there was a vicious one or julia one
would that be like is that even an
option is vicious
you
and
therapy you need help you're a damaged
human being
i am vicious i'm a gemini therefore this
makes sense right
your personality matches vicious you are
cunning ambitious and fierce like
vicious you're a natural-born leader who
is constantly trying to prove themselves
you're someone who wants to forge their
own path and not have to listen to
others that sounds like a
truth that sounds like an optimistic
view i think there's a
a different reading
of the same personality okay so this is
me and mo your personality matches spike
you are adventurous charismatic and
witty like spike you're someone who
loves exploring the world around you wow
you sometimes get into trouble you
always manage to find a way out of it
you're very protective of your friends
very interesting
how long did it take to like come up
with the algorithm also i was kind of
bummed that no one was faye what does it
take to be faye what were the choices
was it the potato chips you can't
reverse engineer this
what's going on how do i get faye mine
says your personality matches jet you
are compassionate honest and trustworthy
like jet you always try to see the good
in people and you always believe
everyone's heart is in the right place
while you love adventure you also love
spending a quiet night in with your
friends
thanks guys you can also find out what
character you are on cowboy bebop by
clicking the link in the description box
you can check out cowboy bebop on
netflix
yeah watch it we think it's awesome yeah
exactly we hope you do too
[Music]